this is a huge scale for me this is one
of my favorite people this is David
Wolfe raw food enthusiast nutrition
expert and just like one of the weirdest
and strangest hippie dippie what do you
want me to say hippie depths hippie
dippie trippy dudes just for people
watching David Wolfe has plugged me into
some of the weirdest and most wild stuff
that I'm basically high on all day I
brought you back a very special
chocolate made by a friend of mine in
Cusco Peru and you can see right there
everybody look at that you can see some
green powder that's in that chocolate
and it is coca okay this is the whole
plant this is the whole plant you need
actually about three trash bags full of
that material that that green cocoa
powder in order to make one line of
cocaine really
this is delicious not good yeah but is
this legal
no that's why we're in here boy the
evidence man for the next okay come on
what is this Orman he's been he's been
asking me literally begging me about
Norma's this is a discovery of wormus
that there's minerals in the environment
that don't fit into the periodic table
of the elements
that's the discovery and that's a that's
a major discovery
but what way I did is I actually took a
gold coin and we stripped out the
impurities and we pushed it back into
this form I'm like a baby bird this is
LSD kept we can't sing that song one
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna go
around the park here this is a Los
Angeles Park and we're gonna go around
and David who's a good forager is going
to forage for anything we could possibly
eat along the way and maybe we'll even
find some weird water that we can drink
and maybe I'll back
who's a very touchy subjects like
religion politics it is this is an
elderberry right here and it's actually
a toxic plant except it's berries and
just the berries not any part of the
stem are edible is that FDA approved it
is definitely not FDA approved you told
me a friend named raw yeah yeah and you
go buy avocado I go buy avocado do you
have a friend named kale yes
no guy's name was Caleb is Caleb and we
just shortened it to kale didn't you a
website uses how amp juice yeah
and as the highest food in the world in
zinc suck it guys not eating ants this
is an invasive species from Chile called
Nicotiana Galka it's a tobacco put that
in your pipe and smoke it put that in
your pipe okay okay we're gonna play a
game called would you eat I want to see
how hard core you worm goji berries yes
goji berries but I didn't wash him yes
goji berries but I didn't wash him but
they're not organic
no okay goji berries they are organic I
did wash them yes then I watched him in
tap water ooh no you think well you
can't eat this grass can you and the
answer is yes you can and actually
that's better for you than wheatgrass
and it tastes good I ripped off the
dirty part look I'm a cow instead of
doing like wheatgrass that you're
growing you come out here and you get
the wild grass juice drink that and you
will be high for 12 to 14 hours like
best time ever rolling around on the
floor giggling free yeah for you it is a
lot of trial and error you eat it you
see how it tastes you see how it feels
and then six hours later you see what it
did it's what we call the great poop
experiment do you smoke weed you seem
like you don't smoke weed yeah when
you're a hippie dude I'm so glad
watching the show right now it's gone
run home show well we don't want to
offend most of our audience because that
is a good impression of them
maybe I know this is a silly question
but would you consider this organic
because it's just it's like this dirt is
naturally occurring right yeah God made
dirt dirt don't hurt preaching let's
play merry kale but with food raw
chocolate goji berries rice crispy treat
ok race crispy treat is obviously kill
yeah
goji berry is cuz it's a female energy
and then raw chocolate Mary it's a the
berries of female yeah it's like a Halle
Berry that is like any question that was
really good I taste like a leaf kick
coconut butter and cacao butter mix
together 5050 as a loose sex oil sex um
how to say that once I see a sexy oil
spread a lady spread okay how would work
use it as a spread for the lady who then
spreads for her vagina to be penetrated
by the condom on this is not gonna make
it on TV
we're on very late at night a tree is
actually a miniature spring it's the
same exact kind of setup but steal some
water right found a spring no big deal
we're able to get a lot of really good
surprisingly clean and clear water check
that out obviously you weren't always
this way you're now obsessed with eating
the best things ever but you grew up I
grew up on fruity pebbles fruit loop to
the worst step ever so I thought you
know what if I just switch to the best
stuff ever yep been doing that for 25
years and say my where we are just a
couple limbs getting water from a park
you can only drink it are you getting
your eyes just go black David Wolfe
amazing thank you so much it's always a
pleasure to see you thanks for being
weird and trippy as you are and thanks
for sharing that with us right on thanks
Pete home food basket
you